some of the most famous and notable scps
in the database are what some of us
would call monsters i bet you can think
of some off the top of your head right
everyone even loosely familiar with the
scp foundation can recall some anomalies
that are famous not because of their
history or their power but because of
their terrifying tendency to prey on
humans indiscriminately there's the
legendary scp-682 which is the perfect
predator invulnerable to any kind of
attack or wound it instantly adapts to
whatever was used to attack it and
regenerates any lost flesh or material
it's not just hard to kill it can be
downright impossible though the
foundation is constantly working on some
new technique and hoping for success in
case that wasn't all terrible enough
it's also actively hateful of all life
around it seeking to exterminate every
living thing or take
scp-939 a pack of four-legged beasts
with bright red skin and ice-cold bodies
they work together to lure in prey and
tear unsuspecting researchers and
civilians to pieces with their long
sharp teeth you might be thinking that
their tactics don't sound too different
from any other pack predator like wolves
or coyotes but wolves and coyotes don't
steal the voices of people they've eaten
then use the voices to lure in other
humans needless to say the scp-939
instances are under intense surveillance
and who can forget about scp-106
the famous old man who preys upon the
living and sucks the unwary children and
d-class into his pocket dimension where
he can engage in an eternal game of cat
and mouse with him unlike the others
scp-106 isn't just predatory it's
downright sadistic it likes to play with
its food and enjoys the struggle of
watching them try to escape the
foundation barely has a handle on how to
contain it and they're constantly hoping
that it doesn't try to breach
containment and result in even more
innocent casualties you can see why the
scp foundation is so wary and paranoid
about scps that are predators preying on
humans
scp-1788 isn't a monster or predator
though at least not directly instead
scp-1788 is a specific kind of process
treatment or ritual the foundation's
researchers aren't totally confident on
what it is yet but they know that
whatever it is it causes a frightening
horrifying transformation on whoever the
unwilling victim of it is we call these
creatures scp-1788-1
instances the foundation currently has
no idea who or what created scp-1788
and why but they're performing active
and constant research including
investigating all the groups of interest
who would create something like this
scp-1788-1 are much larger than a normal
human they're almost always obese in
fact once they're fully grown they
appear anywhere from 150 to 200
kilograms but don't be fooled by
appearances they might look like they're
simply fat but the insides of their
bodies are filled with muscle and dense
bone making them easily 250 to 300
kilograms in actual weight we'll go into
their internal anatomy more in a second
but for now let's return to the outside
of their bodies when you look at
someone's face what's the first thing
that you notice it can be their nose
their hair but nine times out of ten
it's probably their eyes and
scp-1788-1 instances might fool you in
that regard their eyes are slightly too
large for their face just enough to
weird you out if you looked at them
though you probably wouldn't be able to
put your finger on what exactly was
wrong about them when instances get hot
and perspire their sweat is chemically
unbalanced it has high levels of
potassium and copper enough to show up
on tests but still firmly in the normal
range for adult humans as you can see
the changes to
scp-1788-1 instances from the outside
are pretty hard to tell but on the
inside it's a totally different story
their internal anatomy has been
extensively changed during the first
dissections the foundation researchers
didn't even realize these creatures were
originally human at first the instance
is long bones such as the ones in their
arms and legs and cranium are super
dense and thick more so than any normal
human and they're not just made of bone
either they're interwoven with thick
strands of heavy metals making them
super strong and powerful their muscles
on the other hand have been reinforced
in a totally different way the
researchers are still studying tissue
samples but it seems that the muscle
fibers have been modified into shapes
resembling carbon nanotubes molecular
structures that are super light while
still being stronger than steel evidence
derived from numerous physical tests run
on the instances have shown that because
of these structural modifications
scp-17a
instances are much much stronger faster
and have the ability to withstand
punishment far beyond the threshold of
any normal humans
scp-1788-1 instances also possesses
redundant organ systems for several of
the human body's vital processes backup
organs basically when one of the normal
humans primary organs stop working they
usually die but
scp-1788-1 instances can just switch to
using the backup organ and keep going
the most obvious example is the fact
that they have a second heart and that
it can either function independently if
the main heart stops working or it can
work together with the main heart to
give the instance much faster
respiration and breathing abilities
that's part of why they're able to move
so fast speaking of their circulatory
system some of their blood vessels have
locks that can shut off as necessary
their digestive respiratory and nervous
systems all also have redundant organs
that's right
scp-1788-1 instances have a second brain
rather than in the head the second brain
is located in the chest inside its own
ribcage the researchers are baffled by
this part of the
scp-1788-1 instances anatomy they
haven't been able to figure out what
this brain does normally when the first
brain is still working but they have
seen that if the first brain is
destroyed this second brain can take
over to some limited capacity they saw
it firsthand when a team of scp
foundation agents lured an
scp-1788-1 instance into a kill zone and
an mtf sniper blew open its head but
despite its brain and most of its
sensory function being utterly destroyed
the monster kept going and was able to
subdue other agents before being brought
down another main difference in the
overall anatomy of an
scp-1788-1 instance from a normal human
is its arms more specifically that it
has extra arms a second pair of arms sit
just below the regular main arms
extending out of the armpits they're
much smaller but they're just as strong
and flexible and testing has shown that
scp-1788-1 instances can use all four
arms at the same time if they need to
but to maintain their cover most of the
time instances just hold the second arms
folded up and close to their sides where
nobody can tell they're there from the
instance's massive size when an instance
is wearing clothes and has their arms
folded up it's almost impossible to tell
which is an
scp-1788-1 instance and which is just a
normal if obese human being as you can
see
scp-1788 causes quite a few drastic
changes to the human body in fact you
can probably say that these creatures
aren't even properly human anymore but
despite all these changes
scp-1788-1 instances are as you can also
see really hard to differentiate from
regular humans the perfect stealth
predator right but what exactly do
instances do with all these additional
abilities and modifications well like we
said the second part of
scp-1788 changes the behavior of the
people it infects namely they become
predatory the behavior of
scp-1788 instances was hard to observe
since finding them at all was such a
difficult task but eventually the
research team located a large group of
scp-1788-1 instances living in the same
large metropolitan city the foundation
set up covert observation teams
stakeouts reconnaissance agents and
essentially blanketed the city in a net
of surveillance before long every little
movement and action of the
scp-1788-1 instances was recorded in the
foundations database they observed that
as soon as
scp-1788-1 instances hit adulthood they
would typically settle down in large
cities just like the one the foundation
was staking out they'd find a job most
likely it would be in white-collar work
and middle management but one thing that
became evident was that none of them
would ever work as teachers nurses or
any other job where they would come into
regular contact with kids at first no
one realized this pattern once the
foundation realized what was going on
they also realized there was nothing
else to learn from just observing them
they had to get an instance into
containment to try and interrogate them
a lot of good agents lost their lives in
the multiple attempts that were made to
tranquilize sedate capture or otherwise
lure
scp-1788-1 instances into containment
but eventually a few were shot up with
enough tranquilizer to bring down an
elephant and dragged back to the site
but all attempts to force the
scp-1788-1 in the containment cells to
surrender any knowledge failed they
seemed invulnerable to pain torture
coercion
interrogation all methods failed to
glean any important knowledge about
their motives from them but all the
instances the foundation captured while
the personnel who contained and
researched them could only describe them
as deeply evil they were cruel and
narcissistic they would only speak to
communicate their superiority over their
captors and mock personnel for trying to
stop them they weren't stupid though
quite the opposite the researchers
recorded very high iqs and
problem-solving skills during
intelligent tests and they'd often
psychoanalyze their own researchers into
revealing details about themselves it
didn't take long for the site directors
to ban all human contact with captured
instances unless they manipulate
personnel into freeing them meanwhile in
the city surveillance teams were still
monitoring instances that couldn't be
captured by the foundation's strike
teams they watched them at their jobs in
their cars and at their homes they
noticed that despite there being about
half a dozen
scp-1788-1 instances in that one city
they seemed to intentionally avoid each
other at all costs they took jobs at
different companies lived in different
parts of town shopped at different
stores by sheer coincidence three
scp-1788-1 instances showed up at the
same sporting event they seemed to
instantly realize what was going on and
all left the stands at the same time the
undercover agents on duty followed and
tracked them to the bathrooms there they
discovered a grisly sight the
scp-1788-1 instances were in the
deserted bathroom violently beating each
other against the walls with all four of
their fists they were hitting hard with
no regard for their cover identities and
spraying blood against the floor they
were fighting not for survival but to
establish dominance the gender didn't
matter the female instance was fighting
just as brutally as the two male ones
and beaten just as harshly after several
minutes of this violent show of force
two of the instances were treated out of
the bathroom submitting the territory to
the dominant victor of the fight they
quickly left the event entirely the
foundation confirmed this with the few
instances they had contained when two
were put in the same cell they'd fight
for dominance they quickly realized it
was important to ensure that instances
were kept separate at all times lest
they kill each other and rob the
foundation of a living test subject
there weren't many instances to begin
with while multiple of the monsters were
observed in the same city they kept a
strict ratio of one
scp-1788-1 instance for every 100 000
humans the same behavior apex predators
like bears and sharks practice this
behavior of avoiding each other happens
for almost the entire calendar year at
first the foundation thought this
avoiding practice never stopped but
about a year into the surveillance
program something seemed to change
several of the tagged
scp-1788-1 instances in the city
actively began to gravitate toward each
other's territories the foundation
prepared for the inevitably brutal
fights but something even stranger
happened they met each other and didn't
fight in fact they went into each
other's homes the recon teams reported
that the
scp-1788-1 instances were in fact mating
with one another apparently an annual
mating season causes this change in
behavior the
scp-1788-1 mated and then left each
other as quickly as they'd met needless
to say
scp-1788-1 instances are horrifying apex
predators the foundation's research and
observation teams have gleaned quite a
bit about their anatomy and behavior
respectively but many of the personnel
still hold the burning question why
why do
scp-1788-1 instances hunt what's the
motivation well their uncooperativeness
with interviews makes finding out any
details into their thought process
virtually impossible however there was
one occurrence where one of the captured
instances accidentally let something
slip one of the site directors was
attempting to interrogate an instance
using an electroshock collar at first
the instance brushed off his questions
saying the name on his id was his child
name and when asked by the director what
it wanted from regular people it gave a
simple sneering response grow up or die
now go check out scp-5094 miss j's whiz
kid schoolhouse and scp-053 young girl
for more kid-related anomalies from scp
explained